gut ich hätte eine hypothetische frage
ich mag keine hypothetischen frage ich
glaube die richtige frage magst du auch
recht hast du die dokumente noch nicht
gibt einen entscheidenden satz in diesem
film
und der heißt zeitungen sind nicht für
die regierenden sondern für die
regierten gut die bedeutung dieser
institution der vierten gewalt presse
wird durch den film so unfassbar
eindrucksvoll deutlich dass man es
vollkommen hingerissen ist obwohl die
nacht überhaupt nichts passiert die
einzige handlung der sache ist diese
moralische frage welche rolle spielt
presse
es ist nicht der ganze bericht aber über
4000 seiten daran die pentagon papers
sind von einem ehemaligen
verteidigungsminister herausgegebene
geheim dokumentation über den
vietnamkrieg darin erfährt die
öffentlichkeit über geheime absprachen
im kontext des vierten anstiegs seit
sechs jahren lächeln wir hinterher und
jetzt stand ist präsidentin der
vereinigten staaten der nebenbei bemerkt
aber noch auf die pressefreiheit haben
wir das material und konkurrenz haben
wir auch keiner da stecken dutzende
stories drin die times hat kaum die
oberfläche angekratzt
die new york times ist die erste zeitung
die darüber berichtet und nixon der
damalige präsident fängt sofort an diese
veröffentlichung juristisch zu
unterbinden
und was jetzt passiert und der film
handelt ist die frage wie geht man als
eine zweite zeitungen ich damit um der
richard nixon den ich kenne wird die
ganze macht seines amtes nutzen
und wenn es einen weg gibt eine zeitung
zu vernichten bei gott dann findet er
ihn die öffentlichkeit hat ein recht
darauf dass eine funktionierende presse
gibt die ihnen geheimnisse
wenn sie eben in so einer sache des
vietnamkriegs ebenso relevant sind dass
sie darüber informiert wird und deswegen
ist der film eigentlich ein enorm
starkes plädoyer sich darüber nach
wieder gedanken stärker zu machen in die
weltpresse und publikationen eigentlich
zum wesen einer demokratie dazu gehören
sie eben auch befeuern und bestärken was
würde passieren wenn wir es nicht
veröffentlichen
wir werden verlieren das land wird
verlieren
[Musik]
was werden sie tun muss ist der ganze
spannungs ablauf des 50 jahren dass es
in echtzeit erzählt wird also die
entscheidung die getroffen werden für
druck- oder nicht passiert eigentlich
mit einem tag ja wird es gedruckt oder
nicht und das ist ein psychothriller der
besonderen art und ganz herausragenden
muss man wirklich sagen ist meryl streep
die die verlegerin spielt die in st
drei viertel des films herüberkommt als
eine sehr unsichere zwei filme mit ihrer
rolle als leiterin die frau eine frau an
der spitze einer eine einer solchen
zeitung zu der zeit ein 70 noch absolut
ungewöhnlich das ist sehr mutig aber kay
ist in einer position die sie nicht für
möglich gehalten hat und die sie nach
der meinung vieler anderer leute gar
nicht haben sollte und dann gibt es
diesen unglaublichen moment wenn die
wenn die sache umkippt wenn sie nämlich
anfängt zu verstehen dass es hier um
mehr geht es geht hier um eine
entscheidung die politische bedeutung
hat für das ende des vietnamkriegs auch
ein händler und diesen ton den die
märkte auf eine unfassbar prägnante art
und weise vollführt den lohn schon
alleine der ganze besuch dieses films
als einer seiner vertrauten berater der
außerdem weiß was dir diese firma
bedeutet bin ich besorgt
ich habe zehn jahre in washington
gearbeitet ich kenne diese leute bobby
und linden das waren zehn burschen aber
nixon ist anders dem film sollte jeder
schauen der in irgendeiner form
interesse an demokratie und der frage
hat woraus lebt eigentlich so was wie
eine gesellschaft wo es lebt heute auch
im 21 jahrhundert in unserer zeit die so
unfassbar schwierig zu durchschauen ist
wovon lebt da eigentlich öffentlichkeit
in öffentliche meinung und welche rolle
welche wirklich verantwortungsvolle
rolle haben hat eine zeitung und hat
einen publikationsorgan in diesem riesen
mischmasch aus nacht wirtschaftpolitik
moral welche rolle kommt da einer
zeitung zu und in welcher form ist es in
der tat mehr als nur das erfahren von
informationen
eine zeitung zu lesen eine zeitung zu
kaufen dass das großartige pathetische
moment in dem film heißt eben wenn wir
auf die vierte gewalt verzichten wenn
wir meinen im sinne des amerikanischen
präsidenten moment des fake news die
welt regieren kann
dann verlieren wir einige sockel auf den
unser gemeinwesen aufbauen wenn wir das
veröffentlichen stehen wir nächste woche
vor dem obersten gericht und das
bedeutet
wir könnten alle ins gefängnis kommen